the hub network which they say is aimed
at kids but they have the old-school
transformers and GI Joe on there so I
watch all time they are coming out with
a new cartoon it is called shezow and
let's watch a little of the
responsibilities of the boy who became a
superhero to save the world ring turned
you into season good
mama dude no he's a girl
this dress is uncomfortable no she's the
boys who's no he says no he's she's the
boy who's a guy are you ready to kick
some she's out
yeah he's just a guy exactly making the
world a safer place clever
dressed as a girl she's a new hub series
kept your local listings
she's ow
only on hub network check me out I'm a
she Liberty alright so in case you
weren't clear what just happened there
he's a 12 year old boy puts on a ring
becomes a superhero girl I actually had
a very similar experience when I was
ready um all right is this part of the
hardcore left-wing liberal progressive
agenda to turn all our boys into girls
because you know that's coming I think
it's just a silly concept and I think
people are making such a huge deal out
of it for no reason at all yeah although
I would be offended if I started to
watch it and I you know was thinking
that maybe they're making fun of it in a
way then I would be a Friday front of
trans oh yeah in front of girls cuz what
I just was watching that the first thing
I noticed was when he first turned into
a girl he was like no yes it's like
that's like the worst thing you can be
right well that's the funny thing it's
like if they wanted it if they were
trying to be Pro trans or Pro
cross-dressing or something he would
exactly and in this it's like he is
still playing on this no it's not right
kind of thing which I think takes away
from whatever the controversy would be
yeah yeah oh you go ahead well I was
just saying I know their target
demographic is 2 to 11 and I really
don't think these kids are sitting there
right analyzing whether or not like
they're like oh man like this
transgender thing is really like you
know stirring the pot you know I think
they're just seeing this boy it's
entertaining if anything it's smart
because you're appealing to the little
boy market in the girl market you know
is one in the same and that equals money
and that is smart yeah it's very
accurate actually because if you want to
save the world you kind of have to be a
woman yeah do you have a special ring I
do you do it but and yet you're not
wearing it's a nuvaring ah
and go line up high up five out of three
guys very good you know it's funny I
remember when I was a kid watching Shira
and watching Jim and Jim was made by the
same people with the same animators that
made GI Joe and transformers and Shira
was made by the he-man people but I
remember thinking that I was doing
something wrong because I was watching
it because it was aimed at girls did you
guys have that kind of thing where you
maybe watched like a GI Joe or something
where that seemed more boyish and like
do I wonder if girls have that or was it
all about Barbies I liked Power Rangers
and there are some girls there so that's
okay I I'm I like mixed company
apparently I'm bisexual so I like
everyone I like guys and girls uh yeah I
mean yeah I understand that I feel like
I got a comment the other day about this
guy saying is it bad that I watch Pretty
Little Liars and I was like dude own it
that shows amazing yes of all what is
that well even in adults that we think
that somehow watching something is good
like are straight people hanging on to
their identity by such a in yes lovely
is that what it is cuz gay people don't
watch gay people are inundated with
straight images all the time aren't
suddenly like well I better be straight
with straight people if they see
anything gay they're like oh my god yeah
okay I know guys watching the notebook
was like I mean it was okay like alright
I just had to go with her you know but I
think it goes back to that whole
challenging that kind of you know male
perception of strength and
heterosexuality but it's like if you
look back in the history of cartoons
it's not like this is the first time
that the homosexual or transgender any
type of plan that has been represented I
mean you have Batman and Robin Boy
Wonder you know you have Fred Flintstone
who you know was Twinkletoes Flintstone
hung out with Barney like all the time
yeah Bugs Bunny was a crossdresser all
these money know Popeye was a sailor who
was dating a what Olive Oyl could have
been as trans as she got you never know
right yeah yeah yeah well it seems to me
that there's the one part of this that I
think is that they're aiming it at kids
and people seem to think that we can
we can turn kids and that's the scary
part here that that still exists is that
is the bigger fright I think that is a
huge problem I I think people are
reading too much into it I think it's
just a silly little cartoon I don't I
don't see the problem with it at all if
anything it's just making people it's
making people watch something that's
about a guy and a girl at the same time
yeah and also kids just don't realize
this stuff right like when I was 10
watching Bugs Bunny and he was
cross-dressing like I never thought it
was sexual I could just seem funny to me
so it's like yeah the irony is that like
really with them making this more of an
issue it's like that it's bringing it to
life
you know I don't think it would have
even been noticed or by kids or anything
yeah ironically we're gonna have this
for kids but are there any trans
characters on television right now are
there that much there might be one or
two but like any sort of mainstream well
mystique in the accident anyone yeah and
she has yeah yeah yes yeah Candis Cayne
used to be on oh god what show is it I
can't do you know I can't escape yeah
yes she she had a role on some
mainstream show was like my doctor Sam
yeah and it's like I think is that what
do I see yeah all right well I guess we
got a way to go but the people of hub
will lead us to general equality
you